comes the total comfort of total
stainless steel shaving
steel is 50 times harder than human hair
yet if you're a frequent shaver your
razors probably don't last more than a
few weeks before they need to be
sharpened or
tossed in the trash men report each
gives 10
15 even more comfortable shaves watch
for a long time researchers suspected
this failure stemmed from the sharp tip
gradually wearing down and becoming
rounder after each use
but a new study points to a more complex
interaction between hair and steel
involving chipping they started with an
unusual first step
growing a beard the researcher grew a
beard for three days
shaved it then looked at the razor under
an electron microscope
after each shave they didn't notice
metal slowly and evenly coming off the
blade
instead they noticed something baffling
the formation of tiny cracks
then chips along the sharp edge of the
blade
to better understand how these cracks
formed researchers rigged a razor and
hair under a microscope to watch the
cutting in action
when the hair was cut exactly
perpendicular to the blade
no cracks formed but when the blade was
tilted at an angle
conditions more realistic for shaving
they saw those same mysterious
chips changing the angle increased the
stress exerted on the razor
after analyzing the blades further they
found the roughness of the edge of the
razor played a role in the formation of
these chips
despite how smooth a razor may look to
the human eye the surface is speckled
with bumps even before cutting anything
steel is hard overall but there are some
regions that are softer than others
these variations lead to bumps that
render razor blades less effective
researchers found that the cracks were
more likely to form where softer regions
and harder regions met
when the hair pushed down the softer
area at an angle
it stressed the boundary leading to the
formation of a crack
now that researchers understand why the
blade is failing they're working to
create longer lasting razors
traditionally razors are made by honing
steel using a hard rotating wheel to
remove material
and form a sharp tip but this process
results in an uneven
surface to create a smoother tip
researchers have experimented with using
extreme pressure to mold the material
into a sharp wedge shape
soon they hope to test these blades to
see if they are more durable
increasing the lifetime of razors could
have positive environmental impacts
in 1990 the environmental protection
agency estimated that over 2 billion
razors were thrown away annually
with new blades we can cut that waste
off at the source
there it is